A young wrestling phenom from Kentucky,
Aaliyah Svec is just 10 years old,
but Southern Living reports she just beat out
a boatload of older middle school boys
to earn second place at the State Finals.
Hey, Aaliyah, look at...
(audience applauds)
And you know, she was given the choice
to wrestle against kids her own age,
or a level up and compete against boys
that were two to three years older,
and Aaliyah chose to go for the bigger challenge.
And at the competition, she pinned her first opponent
in 19 seconds.
Wow.
Yes, Aaliyah.
(audience applauds)
And next up, Aaliyah's going to go,
hoping to go to Tulsa, in November,
to compete for an Olympic rating,
and you can go to our website for details
on how you can support her journey,
and I am inspired, Drew.
You know what I wanna do right now?
Huh?
I wanna wrestle.
(audience laughs)
I do, I wanna wrassle.
Would you hit it with me?
Oh, I...
One, two, three, four,
I declare a thumb war.
Oh, thumb war,
why don't we do arm wrestle?
Oh, okay, let's arm wrestle!
That's hardcore.
Okay, ready?
Saddle up there, partner.
(audience applauds)
Can you do this?
I don't know.
I think my wrist is too dainty to arm wrestle.
(audience laughs)
Okay, ready?
One, two, three, (strains)
Oh, ow, ow, why are you so strong?
You're freakishly str... (slaps counter)
That's not fair.
Come on, man.
That's not fun.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Really?
What's wrong with you?
You guys, I'm not kidding.
She's freaky strong.
(Drew laughs)
You look all nice and then you (growls)
And you're not, like,
you're like Jimmy Fallon.
You don't let people win just to be nice.
At, at all.
Did I really just beat you?
You really did.
I need to work on my upper body strength, yeah.
I have to tell you, this story literally lifted me
like I was getting a facelift with puppet strings.
I heard this story and I was like,
this is the news you can use, stuff.
I'm so in love with Aaliyah.
Yeah.
I totally wanna support her journey.
She's so cool.
That is my position, when I'm waiting for Postmates,
the food delivery.
Oh, is that you?
(audience laughs)
That's what I look like
after I've put my order in online
and I'm waiting for it to come to the door.
That's the position I assume.
But, just her story really does it for me.
Yeah.
I Love her.
I'm so excited.
Only 10 years old too.
Watch out world, for Aaliyah.
(audience applauds)
Did I really beat you?
Yeah, you did.
I'm not thrilled about that.
I am.
You are.
Course you are.
Okay, well,
this is a fun story and really spoke to me.
People love true crime.
Let's just get on with the realities,
true crime rates for everybody.
People are interested in it.
There's a lot of fans of it out there.
And we have a job for you.
Insider reports, Magellan TV is looking for
a true crime fan who can watch crime shows
for 24 hours straight.
This is not for the faint of heart.
You have to watch shows like "Murder Maps"
and "Murder on the Internet" in a full day marathon.
But crime watching pays a hundred dollars per hour,
a total of $2,400.
All you have to do is document
your crime-watching spree on social media.
Ross, could you do it?
Not at all.
Really?
No, I watched two episodes of "Forensic File" once,
I didn't sleep for a week.
(audience laughs)
It's not for me.
The scariest thing I can handle
is when Julia Roberts cut her hair in Steel Magnolias.
(Drew laughs)
That that is like,
that is my line.
Anything scary than that, I'm out.
It's so funny,
I thought you would've been into this?
No. True crime?
Oh.
No.
Okay.
I don't like anything scary.
Are you kidding me?
I live like Belle in Beauty and the Beast.
(audience laughs)
Just like,
a cartoon bird lands on my shoulder.
I only want happiness.
Well, I guess it depends.
"90 Day Fiance" can be a little scary.
(bright music)